pas écouté le crime à traces du plus
grand des scélérats aviateurs et avocats
qui du crime avait la bosse dans le vi a
bouleversé toute une locale de puissants
najaf ont-ils eu ce scélérat consommé tu
es des mouches tant qu'ils pouvaient et
même des oiseaux utile les mâles et les
femelles rien n'échappe à ce cruel
non content de ces divers dont il tient
un compte exact sur un carton qu'on
trouve à dans la boîte carnassière ce
scélérat une humain son attaque à l'être
humain pour tromper la bourgeoisie vêtu
comme président il met un col d'astrakan
l'article de fantaisie info quand
lancelot qu'il déguise en dérision bon